frank tony congratulations you've made
it to the final round of this
competition which means that you're both
one step closer to the title and 10
grand
now we're sending you back to your home
for just to recreate an iconic weapon
from history
the sicka sword
the sikka is a short but dangerous sword
widely used by gladiators in ancient
rome since it was customary to fight
with armor the blade featured a sharp
curve specifically designed to get
around an opponent's shield a gruesome
killer warriors would use its lethal
inner edge to sever limbs or the blade's
deadly point to hook into the jaw and
pierce through the head today the sick
is often depicted in popular culture
during graphic gladiator battles most
notably in the television series
spartacus blood and sand
good luck blade smiths we'll see you in
five days
my name is tony fetters i'm 56 years old
i was a swat sniper for about eight
years i haven't decided what i'm gonna
do with the ten thousand dollars when i
win it but i'm sure the wife's gonna let
me know
the biggest thing i got to do is get my
welds perfect because if they are
tight my billet can fall into pieces
bending a piece of steel could be
difficult it's a drastic bend but
i got this the heat treat is what gives
the blade life without a good heat treat
you just have a hunk of steel
oh wow
it's got a bow in it
i have to get this warped out fast
i was able to fix the warp
for the handle they use the mahogany
wenge mahogany's a lighter material
wanna use a really dark material so they
make a good contrast and then i used
brass as part of the blade guard
and put the pieces together
i believe this sword will outperform
franks both aesthetically and
functionally i think it'll work
[Music]
my name is frank sausto from the bronx
and i'm a plumber by day at a zoo
i only got four years experience
but i know i can make good blades i just
want the rest of the world to know i
hope i don't get sent on the first one
that would suck
i've made curved blades before
nothing like this
we're getting there just got to keep
going
boom and that's at 27.
wow that looks like a hockey stick try
to profile out that tip a little bit i'm
confident in my work the crunch tank i
have now is a little too thin and the
blade will not fit
so i had to come up with something
you really shouldn't make a crunch tank
out of a wood box there's usually a lot
of flames when you punch a blade so you
definitely flame up i really put
everything i had into it getting this
angle right
and during the quench the blade could
warp or break or shatter
all that work could just be for nothing
no warps
overall my blade looks awesome i'm doing
a seven piece construction with nine
pins holding it all in place
this is the first time i've ever done a
hidden tang through a set of scales
all this stuff is going to show and put
me apart from tony's blade
all i got to do is shape it and polish
it and sharpen it and it's ready to go
oh look at this a message
from my competitor
looking forward to the test
i can't wait
time to do some battle smiths this is
the kill test i'll take your seeker
sword and deliver killing blows on this
ballistics dummy
frank you're up first you ready hell
yeah let's do this i put my awl into
this blade i'm just hoping it just takes
the head right off this dummy
bladesmiths i'm still recuperating from
an injury so please welcome staff
sergeant chris manz of the us army today
he will have the pleasure of testing
your weapon
[Music]
nice
well frank your blade is sharp
in combat the sick is sometimes using
this curve to pull away the sword and
come in in this case he pulled away the
head
overall your weapon
will kill thank you
tony you ready
let's have some fun
all right tony this is a scary sicka
sword
on the initial hack into the chest
cavity it penetrated so deep it totally
demolished this ballistics dummy overall
sir your weapon
will kill
tony's blade just performs great on this
thing i mean even though they both will
kill
it's just looked a little bit more
violent so it has me a little a little
nervous
gentlemen this is the strength test in
order to test the strength and
durability of your glades i'm going to
attack these shields
remember this test is all about what the
shields do to your weapons and not what
your weapons do to the shields
frank you're up first are you ready yep
let's do this
[Music]
well frank
your edge held up perfectly all right
it's still straight it's still sharp
everything is still tight and solid
well done thank you
tony you're up next you ready yes
well tony
your edge held up perfectly as well
razor sharp i see
no problem with the edge from the shield
you know a nice solid blade well done
thank you
good job
all right gentlemen
now it's the sharpness test i'll be
cutting through this sugar cane one cut
with the front edge of your blade one
cut with the back edge all right frank
you're up first you ready oh yes
[Music]
all right frank right off your blade's
got a really nice balance to it
you can see on that first cut it kind of
pulled in my hand but it's still a good
feel on the back cut blew right through
any gladiator using this be quick be
deadly well done thank you all right
tony you're up you ready for this yep
[Music]
so tony
is it sharp yes it's very sharp and it
cut very nicely
still right still tight
well done thank you
bladesmiths over the course of three
rounds both of you has displayed
excellent bladesmithing talent however
in this arena of competition there can
only be one champion
tony
congratulations you are the new forged
and fire champion
frank unfortunately your weapon did not
make the cut
frank first up i want to say that there
are no losers in this round but we can
only pick one winner both weapons were
very sharp both weapons are very strong
but the sikko was a gladiator's weapon
and your weapon was outperformed in the
kill test as for that reason we're
sending you home
all right
totally understand frank
please surrender your blade
i'm fine with this result they both
killed but
he's uh really killed
tony's already invited me to come up
there and forage he's going to show me
some stuff
i'll know tony probably the rest of my
life
tony congratulations you are our new
forged and fire champion and that's a
title that comes with a check for 10
grand good job how do you feel right now
i feel pretty good all right well tony
please present your weapon to the judges
just
okay i'm still here it's not a dream
i won it's awesome
how do you put it in words
game i saw in a concord
you